welcome back to my strategy guide on
terraforming Mars episode 4. today we're
going to talk about synergies and then
we're also going to talk about a literal
recipe of how to winning the game of
terraforming masks so here it is this is
like a list of priorities if you will so
this is what I think you should be
looking for at all stages of the games
we got to talk about the opening hand
the early to mid game and the mid to
late game and to be honest it's kind of
impossible to make this list here
without talking about some of the stuff
we talked about in the first three
episodes because Synergy is in terraform
much it's just such a huge entity so
some of this stuff actually most of this
stuff we probably already talked about
but there are also a lot of new stuff in
this video for instance Florida Synergy
is a subject to have a lot to say about
and this is probably the only video
where I'm gonna talk about fluticinity
at all so if nothing else just go to 12
look what I have to say about fluores
energy and then proceed to the next
episode of your arrow that being said I
still think this episode is actually
pretty important because I think it's
very enlightening to realize exactly
what stuff you should be keeping your
eye out for in the different parts of
the game mainly the opening hand the
early to mid game and the mid to late
game so when you get your opening hand
you get 10 cards two corporations a
couple preludes this is what I thing you
should be searching for so first of all
we got money income and card draw when I
get my opening hand this is the first
thing I look for which of these
combination of cards will give me the
biggest engine possible throughout this
episode if this is stuff we only talked
about in the previous episode I'm not
gonna spend too much time repeating
myself today instead I'm just gonna
write on the bottom of the screen here
for example check out episode one tip
number one this is where we talked a lot
about money income but basically it's
anything that helps you to build your
engine so we gotta make a creative
production because still production
titanium production and when you have a
little bit of this going on when you've
climbed out of the hole then you can
look at stuff like brand production heat
production and also we can't have to
take into account the number of players
so in two player games it's really
important to get as much Mega credit
production as you can in five player
games making credit production is still
important but in addition to that you
can also build your engine just by
getting a bunch of TR and stuff like
this and then we get card draw cards and
like we talked about card draw and money
income is like the two different sides
of the same coin you kind of need both
in order to have a good game once again
we kind of talked a lot about card draw
in the last episode but there's still
some important stuff here here I didn't
mention so let's look at it when it
comes to the opening hand I think I
would always keep these three cards here
these three cards are just too good to
pass up and since we are talking about
the opening hand I think I would keep
most of the character I see a few
scenarios and a few cards I might not
keep but as a rule like when you're
starting out the game cutter is really
good because if you play it in the first
generation it's gonna draw you a lot of
cards during the game so in the opening
hand card draws really good you might
not play it in the first generation it's
actually a little bit more important to
just build your engine build your mega
credit production first but then right
after you've done that you play your
card draw and you're gonna get a lot of
cards from this so I'll definitely keep
most of the card Pro cards I see in my
opening hand when it comes to card draw
it's actually easier to explain when not
to go for card draw so for example if
we're not talking about the early game
but if we instead of talking about the
late game instead then some card draw
cards might just be too expensive
especially considering they might only
draw you like one to two cards so is it
really worth to give like a lot of Mega
credits just to draw one card sometimes
it is but mostly it's not for example if
you live in a card like inventor skill
if we're looking at the last generation
of the second to last generation then
you're paying nine Mega credits plus
three for the card plus three for the
action that actually allows you to draw
a card so this is 15 Mega credits just
to get one card if you play this in the
last generation so that's really not
good it could be that you're really
desperate and you're like I need to top
take something amazing and job and
amplify or something to win this game
but as a rule you really don't want to
play 15 Mega credits just for one card
so investor skill if you played earlier
in the game in the early to mid game
then it can actually be quite good
because then you can get a lot of cards
for this to be honest I think this is
one of the weaker card draw cards in the
set it's a bit expensive for what it
gives you I think but it can still be
worth it to play the card because there
is actually one giant redeeming factor
of this card I wonder if you guys can
spot it it's really important so you
need to pay attention now here it is all
the inventors in the pictures Jagger
foxelius who is one of the guys who made
the game and then the Texas win great
minds meet new ideas about it's
brilliant I'm kind of fan buying let's
move on and the second instance where
you would not keep card draw is if you
already have a lot of good cards in your
hand already for example if your hand is
like stacked with like good quality a
lot of high impact cards why would you
need more cards just play the cards you
only have it's fine if your economy is
strong you can still pick up even more
cards to be even more greedy if you
don't have resources to pay for all the
new cards you're getting then maybe it's
not worth it but I mean if you already
have the card broadcast you kind of want
to use it right and this kind of leads
me to the third one is all about how
strong is your economy can you actually
afford to pick up even more card draw
cards because these cards doesn't really
do anything for your engine they're just
here to give you cards and some of them
are pretty expensive so ironically if
your engine is bad then sometimes it's
actually hard to keep these card draw
cards because it's kind of like a luxury
you cannot afford right now what I mean
is sometimes I pick up a card like a
Minton skilled and then I plan to play
this but then I'm like oh I also have to
play my engine and then I have to play
these engine cards first because
otherwise you're not really snowballing
and then this card is just stuck in your
hand and you're never using it so to be
honest it sometimes happens that I buy a
card like Adventure skills for three
Mega credits and then I have it in my
hand the entire game and then in the
last generation I end up selling it for
one Mega credits and obviously this is
terrible so what it really comes down to
is my economy strong enough to actually
play all of these card broadcasts or
number four if you're all in on cities
or the terraforming strategy then
sometimes well like I kind of don't even
need this card draw card because I just
rather want to spend all my resources
doing this one thing that I'm really
good at this game so this hand here for
example this hand is so good that I'm
not all right I'm gonna be all in on
cities nothing else matters I even made
a mistake keeping iron mining Industries
in this opening end I think but
definitely I don't keep Development
Center because all my resources I just
bought cities I want plant production I
don't even need cards at this point this
hand is so good already so if you're
really all in on either cities or
terraforming strategy then it's
sometimes better for you to just go all
in in that direction and then you don't
need so many cards and finally card draw
is even better in two or three player
games because these games tend to be
longer in terms of generations so if
you're playing a two or three player
game or if you have a feeling that this
game is going to go long in terms of
generation then capital is really good
because it's all about the card strategy
in these long games to and the second
thing I look for in my opening hand is
synergy and I know it's a little bit
redundant because this whole thing is
about synergies but mainly I'm looking
for Colony Synergy discount Synergy and
heat Synergy so let's talk about Colony
Synergy first I think this is really
important because I really think almost
all of the colony cars and also the
colony standard project build the colony
for 17 so these are really good so if I
just get a little bit of support for
example standard technology then I might
be more inclined to keep fewer cards in
my opening hand because then I'm more
like all right I'm just going to build a
bunch of colonies it also depends which
colonies are out there but obviously all
the colonies that gives you some sort of
engine to begin with that's what you're
looking for in the early game and also
Pluto so in the first generation I'm
definitely considering Cirrus Luna or
Pluto and also a little bit treated but
Triton is kind of like a weird one
because it doesn't actually give you an
income of titanium but the nice thing
about Triton is like the colony is
really cheap because it costs 17 and
then you get nine back because the
placement bonus is three titanium so
maybe you can use these three titanium
for something nice in the same
generation and also if you are playing
with Colony skating three energy
production is really important you can
do this on Callisto or Europa so here
the colony cards and like I mentioned I
really think all of these cards are
really good maybe except for the two big
ones here on the left but I think all of
the other ones are solid it's not like a
slam dunk you don't automatically just
keep all of these cards the moment you
see them but every time I see these
cards on the right here I'm at the very
least I'm gonna really considered all
right should I keep these cars should I
play these cards and play a lot of
colonies that is something I would
seriously consider when I see some of
these cards here and like we've maybe
mentioned before even if you don't have
any synergies for colleagues you have
nothing then I might still consider
playing one of the colonies especially
Luna over playing a sub-optimal card in
my opening hand so starting hand it has
to be good cars it has to be cars you
want to play otherwise why not just
build the colony instead so if you try
this for example building colony and
Luna or playing this card import of
Advance dhg without having any synergies
for it or anything then obviously Luna
wins I'm I'm sorry I use this light
before I'm I'm kind of biased I like the
slide then we got discount Synergy and a
lot of these cards ever see them in my
opening hand I'm really happy like if
see Earth office even if I don't have
one single Earth tag in my entire hand
except for Earth office I would probably
still keep this car because then during
the game I'm gonna pick up some Earth
tags and worth noting in that case I'm
not actually gonna play yourself as the
first generation I'm only gonna play
this office just before I play another
Earth attack this is like the case with
all of them and Earth catapult I think
the only way I'm not keeping this in my
opening hand is if I'm all in them
cities or all in Ontario farming and
even then I might still consider it at
the very least but it could be the case
that I just want to go all in the cities
and in that case I'm not gonna play with
catapult and obviously if I do have
optimal error braking I would be more
inclined to keep some of the space
events in my opening hand so what I'm
trying to say is you have to look for
synergies in your opening hand you have
to look at all right what are the
effects that's going to benefit some of
the other cars which of these cards play
nicely together there are actually more
discount effects than these cards here
they're also they fixed from the
corporation so here's an example of an
opening hand I had in the game and the
opening end is pretty terrible but I
have this Corporation this Chinese
Corporation I don't have the confidence
to actually say this Corporation out
loud but it doesn't example of a
corporation that gives me two discount
on all building tags so this opening
hand here was not really that good but
at least I had three building tags so I
would be more inclined to go for those
right and worth noting this opening hand
didn't really have any money income
that's only like a little bit of fuel
Factory or something so I just went with
whatever I could get then we got heat
Synergy and like I've mentioned before
I'm not that crazy about heat so why is
this a priority in the opening hand the
thing is I think the heat cuts by
themselves are kind of weak but if you
had some sort of heat Synergy some sort
of heat combo then it could be kind of
good so like I mentioned if I have
optimal airbrake in my opening hand I
might also be more inclined to keep some
of the cheap space of end cards that
also gives me heat or if you have melt
works or helium Corporation or something
like this then definitely you creepy eye
out for all the heat production you can
get it's kind of good in that case
because if you get to this point where
you can get one TR every generation then
it's actually like eight Mega credit
production because one TR is kind of
eight Mega credit it's kind of like the
same deal if you got extreme cold fungus
together with regulate eaters or
something then it's also one Sierra
every generation and that case you could
also make the argument that it's kind of
like eight Mega credit production for a
combo like this but it's a little bit
worse because as soon as the oxygen is
maxed then this combo is completely
useless and if you for example like this
let's be honest annoying person who just
keeps pumping up the oxygen then it will
stand to reason that the oxygen is maybe
the first parameter to close and in that
case this combo could be completely
useless in the second half of the game
the third thing I'm looking for in my
opening hand are my cards supporting
some sort of strategy strategies here
are the ones we talked about in the
previous episode but as we are talking
about the opening hand here it doesn't
make much sense to talk about strategy 1
5 and 6 as these strategies are
something you think about in the mid to
late game but I mean it could be the
case that you have like two German
amplifiers in your opening hand and
obviously you're probably gonna consider
going for jovians this game but even
then I would argue then what you're
focusing on is strategy number three the
card strategy because really the Jovian
and the green text reality those are
extensions of the cash 30 I think so in
my opening hand I'm really just thinking
about strategy two three and four like
the filtered Toyota terraform or the car
strategy of the city strategies just
some of my cards in my hand really
support one of these strategies and then
once again we have to take into account
number of players this is going to be a
short game or a long game because for
example the field to do with the
terraforming strategy that only works if
the game is gonna be short it doesn't
work if it's long game and you might be
thinking well you're at the terraformer
you can just make sure that the game
ends fast but that's just impossible in
two player games you cannot end the game
by yourself in two or three player games
depends on the other players so if I am
looking for cars in my opening hand that
supports the terraforming strategy then
it's probably because this is a four
player game with five player game but in
every game of player probably look for
cards that support the card strategy or
the city strategy and speaking of number
of players this also matters a lot I
think when talking about the two
corporations in my starting hand I think
some people think I'm a little bit
extreme when it comes to this stuff but
I really think it matters if you're in a
two-player game or five play games some
corporations are just better for two
player games and some corporations are
better than 5 play games so the two
player game I'd say that SAS is like B
tier and point Luna is absolutely is
still where they go but Luna amazing
two-player games and in five player
games status is all of a sudden stier
with a goat and Lunas like BT and
another example that really hits this
home for me is like umni this
Corporation is so terrible in two player
games but that's because only is all
about the terraforming strategy and the
terraforming strategy is kind of bad in
two player games right booming two
player games is maybe not as bad as I
make it out to be because to be honest
like if you have like one free tier
every generation then that's kinda nice
but even then it's still just it's bad
Corporation compared to a lot of the
others so often what happens is you're
kind of like grieving your own game just
so you can satisfy this condition you
have to get a TR every round and then
you could get another tier for three
Mega credits I don't think it's good so
all things considered only in a two-play
game I'm pretty sure that's garbage
however only in a five player game then
it's all of a sudden an eight-year
cooperation I think because five player
games is all about the xeroforming
strategy to be honest it's so much
terraforming going on and the game could
be over in like six Generations or seven
generations in that case it's great you
can even use only in a 5K seems to like
ensure that the game doesn't go super
long so even if people have a nice
engine going on you can still punish the
people with the engine by closing the
game super fast and this is something
you can do in five player games because
when there are five players around the
table the games are just gonna be
shorter so really what I'm saying is the
terraforming strategy has a higher
chance of winning in five player games
which also means that Omni as a
corporation has a high of chance of
being successful in five player games
but even in a 5 player game I'm still
not gonna award Omni a goat
I just can't bring myself to do it I'm
not even gonna give it an st I think
it's an eight year it's fine if I ever
awarded a goat to Omni then the goats
themselves would Riot they would Revolt
they would rise up against me start a
revolution and overthrow me throw me in
prison and then in the next morning they
would execute me my building me on the
stage needless to say only will never be
a water good company is really the only
good in five play games maybe four
player games but that's pretty much it
and then we got Vito I put it over here
because I thought alright what
collaboration really comes to mind when
I think about the car strategy there are
a couple of them but one of them is
definitely veto and then I was like this
is for sure according to play games and
maybe it's not so good in five play
games but it's not really like that I
thought about it some more I don't think
Vito is ever a bad Corporation not even
in five player games maybe eight here
for two player games is even a bit low I
I definitely sure that some people will
feel like there's an st Corporation in
two player games I didn't think much of
this Corporation at first but what I've
realized is when you're going for this
car strategy and you are going to go God
mode like getting three Mega credits
every time you pick a card with a VP on
it that's like a big component of how to
go God mode so definitely win more
Corporation if you're going for veto if
you're going for the car strategy and
you're having success with it this
Corporation is insane on the other hand
the early game with this cooperation is
really not good like you don't really
want to play cards with the VP on it
even in the early game so it's really a
slow beginning it doesn't come with any
big credit production or anything so
it's a little bit like pandula in a
sense that if you're getting lucky then
you're gonna demolish everyone and if
you're getting unlucky if you don't
really have any early game if you never
get the cast rate of the oven running
you never go guard mode then what is
this carburation really doing for you
not much taking that into account think
ETA is reasonable even though I'm pretty
sure that some people is going to give
this an st I hope that on this
terraformer mask website something
people are actually really enjoying this
Corporation but getting back to the
starting hand are there anything in my
starting hand that really supports the
terraforming strategy and once again
this is really better if it's a four or
five player game and like we talked
about in the previous video Regal it
eats his DHT producing bacteria these
are not really good cards by themselves
they kind of do need like another card
that can really give them some microbes
for these to be efficient so I'm not a
big fan of regular details and ghd
producing bacteria but then again I'm
not really a big fan of the terraforming
strategy in general so maybe that's what
it is so you could decide to just start
terraforming based on your opening hand
it's like if you don't have any engine
this is what you have go for it so in
four or five player games this is a fine
strategy into three player games this
almost never works only play this if
you're absolutely desperate into a
three-player game so I say that but here
on the starting hand I showed you before
I kind of went for the terraforming
strategy even though it's a three-player
game but I kind of did this out of
necessity than anything else I just
didn't have anything better and so in my
starting hand are there any cups that
support the card strategy so for example
if I have a lot of money income if I
have a lot of card draw then I'm
definitely considering going for the
card strategy so let me show you a
couple of examples of really good
starting hands especially when it comes
to the car strategy I talked a lot about
this starting hand in the previous video
but basically the starting hand it's
amazing why because I can play AI
Central in the first generation and I
have a lot of Mega credit production as
well so if you have both engine and card
draw then your goal in an AR Central in
the first generation that's amazing so
here is literally the best starting hand
you can have this is like me Theory
crafting and that's a little bit of user
made content here so I promise I'll be
brief I have a later episode devoted to
user made content but this is like we're
talking about starting hands we're
talking about synergies just have to
show you this so I'm just going to be
really brief here talk about this really
good and in a second I'm also gonna
substitute the user made caps with
normal cards in case you don't want to
play with you so make content or in case
you don't have user made content but why
is this starting hand so good this is
like everything I talk about in the car
strategy we've got a million cards and
we getting a fair bit amount of Mega
credit production making credits from
other effects and stuff like this a
while back I played a deck that was
pretty close to this one and it was
insane I literally Drew all the cars and
I have like 700 cars I drew all of them
then all of the cars on the discard pile
I also Drew all of those so I drew maybe
like 700 cards in that game and that was
like a year ago and since then we gotten
some new stuff we got new partner merger
some of the new preludes so kind of
optimized the starting hand afterwards
so I haven't actually tried this deck
but it it's completely insane I promise
you anyway this user made stuff we're
going to talk about in episode 13 but
right now I'm just talking about the
Synergy here and the Synergy is like you
imagine I have a ton of cars a ton of my
creative production so here's the player
order I would play the stick in and the
only downside of this deck is it draws
too many cards I'm I'm not kidding
you're drawing the entire deck and then
the game is not over yet and then you
have no more cards to draw so if you
have less than 500 cards in your deck I
would actually recommend you take out on
the second copy list because this
Corporation this card it just draws you
too many cards and also worth noting
copyleft also makes your opponent draw
some cards which is not what you want
when you kind of want to draw everything
so in this case I will substitute those
two with value trust and space relay and
then the preload I get from Valley
Church should be vital colony and then
the vital Colony you actually put a
leave it station so you get four science
tags and two Jovian tags is really cool
but I should probably move on now to be
honest there's a lot of people that
don't really like user made content it
makes sense because it's not really
something that developers made it's not
really balanced in the same way and
stuff like this so real quick just for
those of you who don't want to play with
or don't have user made content you can
actually just remove those and
substitute them for something else and
like you can see there's actually not
that much used to make content here so
instead of these files you could
substitute it with something like this
and interestingly you could actually go
supply drop with Advanced allies because
this gives you a lot of stuff to begin
with so you can actually play this
entire hand a lot quicker violin is kind
of cool you can use it with AI Central
High Tech labor orbital cleanup but I
win with viter because when I'm losing
Dev ride I feel like I was a bit short
on Mega Critters in this deck and Vita
just gives you 800 this is a starting
Deck with only official cards so no more
user Make content and the synergies here
is all over the place so you're going to
draw a million cards you're going to get
a million Mega credits you're gonna play
a million cards and you'll get like a
million points this is like if God mode
was a starting hand this is what it
would look like I'm gonna move on now
I'm gonna do it I'm sorry and just to
throw in a little fun challenge here I
challenge everyone to Theory craft a
better starting hand than this one maybe
you have more user made content that I'm
not aware of or maybe you're just
smarter than me which is entirely
plausible if you do a third craft
something nice rather than the comments
and I'll talk about it in the episode
called feedback so in the starting hand
maybe you have some cards that support
the city strategy so it could be these
cards here and like we mentioned
immigrant City Martian rails fastest
those are kind of the big three if you
want to like build your engine building
cities especially if you want to go for
the terrible City standard project for
25 if you're going to build this
terrible standard project in the early
game it's good later but until the game
is terrible so if you're gonna do that
you definitely need an data City support
so I need like two out of three
immigrant City margin real fastest it
could also be the case that you just see
a couple of these cards on your opening
hand maybe one or two or three and then
you're like all right maybe I'm just
gonna to build cities in the second half
of the game and then you're gonna build
your engine with something else with
cards most likely and then in the mid
game you're gonna get a lot of playing
production and then the mid to late game
you're just gonna place a lot of cities
with these cities energetic cards you
have and then you've got to plant a lot
of greeneries around your cities also
reasonable other City energetic cards
could be immigrant journals standard
technology if you are going for the
standard project at least could also be
greenhouses although greenhouses is
better to pick up in the mid to late
game because this is really a late game
card this card is so good in the last
generation or something let's say
they're like eight cities on the map
which is entirely reasonable since
you're going for City so that's probably
going to be even more than greenhouses
like at least one Greenery the last
generation is pretty common to spend 23
Mega credits to get a Greenery down so
if you can get this for six plus three
for the card so nine that's a really
good deal if I am going for cities I
might even pick this card up in the
early game just so I can play it in the
last generation that's how good this
card is and like we mentioned if you are
going for cities it's kind of nice to
see what a Dream City starting opening
hand is and this is it this is like Kilt
farming plus ecology experts combo
really nice and got a bunch of CDs a
bunch of plant production just like
everything you want when you're going
for cities except this hand is maybe
missing immigrant City and Martian rails
but you know you can't get it all but
the city in this hand is so good that I
actually even regret going fire mining
Industries which is crazy and then
number four in my list of priorities of
what stuff to go for in my starting hand
we got milestones at least planning
which Milestones to aim for this game so
it's worth noting that Milestones are
pretty low in my priorities in the
opening hand I'm sure a lot of people
don't agree with this I think a lot of
people look at a game of Terror for a
mouth see the opening Handler alright
which Milestones can I go for Nothing
Else Matters I only care about the
Milestones I don't think this is a good
approach I think the stuff we talked
about so far is even more important than
milestones and then Milestones is kind
of nice if you can get a milestone
that's on your road anyway or if you
have to take a little detail to get a
milestone it's also fine but just don't
go all in on Milestones like if you see
the Maya Mars on you see I got focused
space save and early settlement and then
I can buy a city this is such a bad play
you just instantly gonna lose the game
just so you could get the mayor mouth
done it's not that important to be
honest so in the the other game and also
in the opening hand you should
definitely have milestones in the back
of your head like maybe some cards are
supporting a milestone somehow and you
can get like an idea of what you might
want to go for this game and in any game
you should always aim to get at least
one Milestone but on the other hand in
your opening hand it's not really that
important because one of the other guys
thus is then you're like oh A Cap
City is just so I can get the mayor but
this guy faster so I'm probably gonna
lose that anyway because in your opening
hand you have no idea what your
opponents are actually gonna go for this
game you haven't even seen their
corporations at this point so even if
you're keeping like a lot of cards
because I want to get this or that
Milestone then you're not even sure
you're gonna get it because you don't
know what your opponents are doing it
and once again we have to take into
account the number of players because in
two or three play games the Milestones
are less important but in four or five
play games the Milestones are really
important then the five player games I
might be more inclined to pick
sub-optimal cards in my opening hand
just because it's supporting a milestone
and after I've worked through all of
this the first four priorities on this
list so then I get to number five can I
afford keeping some of the good cards in
my and for later the cards that I'm not
gonna play yet but later on they're
gonna be really good can I actually fall
to keep these and the reason this is
like the last one on the list is because
I want to look at the first four points
here first and after I've made a plan of
what I want to do in the first
generation then I can actually calculate
how much Mega credit is going to be left
over so can I afford to spend like three
Mega credits on absolutely nothing right
now just so I could keep a card for
later the two things you should know
it's very expensive to keep a card that
you're not gonna play right now because
three Mega credits in the first
generation is a lot better than three
Mega credits in the last generation and
secondly it's often worth it because
some cards are just so good in the mid
to late game then it's worth keeping
them in the early game even in your
opening hand sometimes so examples of
cards I might want to keep in mind
opening hand well first of all
definitely resource amplifies because
we're still talking about the opening
hand so in the early to mid game this is
when you want to play all of these
resource amplifiers if you can though
it's pretty likely that I'm Gonna Keep
some of these cards here maybe not stuff
like surveillance because of the five
oxygen requirements maybe that quality
Communications if I don't have any
science text and you could go on but
generally speaking I would be very happy
to see these cars and often I would keep
these in my opening hand and especially
the planned amplifiers if I have some
Synergy going on these could be really
good as well to be honest it could also
just be plant production General you
don't really want to play this in first
generation because like we talked about
you really want to get money income but
you could still keep these cards and
play them in the mid game that's
entirely reasonable Jovian amplifiers we
definitely want to consider keeping
those and I gotta keep them every game
but at least we're gonna consider
keeping them the same thing with the
green VP amplifiers I think some of
these cars are really underrated and
they could give a lot of points but
obviously this is only if you're going
for the Green Tech strategy some of the
juicy science cards like these ones
could also be reasonable to keeping your
opening hand even if you don't quite
fulfill the requirement yet so it's kind
of like an estimation you have to make
how many science texts do I have in my
hand and how long is it gonna take
before I can get these down and what if
I never get the last science tag I need
is gonna ruin my game you can also
Gamble and just like hope you get the
science text you needs it's a little bit
risky because if you don't get the
science tag you're kind of start with a
dead card that you play 3-4 on your
opening handle that's not good and once
again number of players also matters
here because generally these cards are
better in two or three player games
because they tend to be longer in terms
of generation especially when we're
talking about AI Central and the gravity
technology amazing cards in two player
games but really risky cards in five
player games so if you want to pick my
brain about what stuff I think about in
the opening hand this is like the list
of my priorities this is like the list I
have in the back of my head maybe
subconsciously and I think a lot of you
guys have this list or something similar
in your head are subconsciously as well
since we are talking about the opening
hand I would be remiss if I didn't
mention some of the stuff we talked
about in the first episode indentured
workers and Luna exports are really good
cast in your opening hand lunar export
gives you 5 Mega credit production and
indented workers is also a great card in
the opening hand even though it gives
you a negative VP because the way logo
did 5 megatrades in the first generation
like with accumulated interest for the
entire game that is gonna be like five
victory points so it's gonna be way
better than the one Victory point you
stand to lose by playing this card this
card actually so good that I pick it up
in the mid game as well I might even
pick it up in the late game so yeah I
really like this car I think a lot of
people disagrees but I think this car is
really good and of course if you break
the money asteroid an Interstellar color
shape terrible Castle you're starting
and don't do it also keep in mind some
of the Trap calves the cards that kind
of look good because it gives you a
production but when you think about it
if you calculate how many generations
before this card actually pays for
itself then it's gonna be not great it
could be the case that you just have
terrible cards in your starting hands so
in that case these can be like a good
plan B a good plan C and to be honest
design microorganisms this card can
actually be okay sometimes so now we've
moved on to the early to mid game so
what is exactly the list of priorities
of stuff I want to focus on in this part
of the game so number six we got
resource amplifiers so once again the
resource amplifiers can be really
powerful and they can straight up decide
the game for you however these cards are
still very situational they don't always
work so you still have to look at is
this a good card for this particular
game but generally speaking I think a
lot of these cards are really good but
it depends on the game of course and it
should go without saying that if you
have insects cards and satellites or
something like this then you should play
to maximize the value of these cars by
playing as many of these tags as
possible before playing the amplifier
within reason and when I say within
reason you probably don't play
terraforming Academy just so you can get
one more Mega credit production from
satellite in the early game that's not a
good idea and also keep in mind this
aspect we talked about the production is
generally better the earlier you get it
down so it's kind of a balancing act
because the thing is a lot of these gold
amplifiers they're like increasing in
value as the game goes on also I should
quickly mention robotic Workforce it can
be really good together with europolies
or medical lab and we talked about the
strategies I'm looking for in my opening
hand and stuff like this but if I have
robotic Workforce and geropolies plus
maybe I don't know two or three Venus or
Earth attacks this is probably going to
be my strategy I don't care about
anything else this is probably just what
I'm doing this game and number seven
finally deciding on a strategy the thing
is even in your opening hand you have an
idea what you're going for but a lot of
things can change during the game you
can pick up some synergies that just
pulls you in another direction or you
can see what your opponents are doing
this is going to be a long game or a
short game so a lot of things can change
in the early game but now that we've
reached the early to mid game you
probably have a pretty good idea of what
your opponents is gonna do what your car
is going to look like and you probably
have a pretty good idea what your
strategy should be so I think this is a
part of the game where I really decide
which strategy I'm going to go for and
as an extension of number seven we go to
number eight should I aim for a short
game or a long game this is also the
part of the game where I think about
this stuff like we talked about on
episode one if you got the greencast the
greedy engine you want the long game and
if your opponent's got the cards and the
greedy engine you want a short game you
don't want to close the game to actually
punish the greedy guy and number nine we
got the milestones and now I'm talking
about actually buying the Milestones
before we were like planning on which
Milestones to go for but now we reached
the early to mid game this is the time
where we're actually trying to buy some
of them so once again here the
Milestones from the base game which is
fastest and also hairless and Elysium so
I know I tend to talk down Milestones a
little bit I don't think it should
dictate how you play your game but that
being said it is of course quite nice to
get 5 victory points for eight Mega
credits so in the early to mid game this
is definitely something you should think
about and technically since the first
award also only cost 8 Mega credit you
can also consider this but to be clear
it's only the first award for 8 Mega
credits and even then you have to be
really sure that you're actually gonna
win it because starting in the world
especially in the early it's a mid game
and then one of your opponents is gonna
beat you in that award that's really bad
that's like game losingly bad and number
10 which is the final priority in the
early to mid game if your economy can
handle it you should really start
picking up VP amplifiers but I'm saying
pick up you shouldn't really play them
yet you should play them at the right
time which is usually either the mid
game or the late game for example if
we're talking about the domain
amplifiers like a 9 out of 10 games you
play these in the very last generation
but that doesn't mean you can't pick up
the cards now the green tag amplifiers
if you're going for green tax energy in
general these cards can also be really
good to pick up and then you play them
around the mid game I would say except
of course for important nitrogen large
Convoy and last ecosystems once again
these cards are probably best to play in
the last generation or at least in the
late game then we arrive at the mid to
late game so first of all plan
production and I kind of feel bad for
putting it here in the mid to late game
because truth be told plan production in
the late game is often not worth it the
mid game is really when you want to play
playing production cards or at the very
least after you've built a money engine
then you can even play playing
production in the early game and the mid
game is also probably when you get to
play some of these plane amplifiers they
can be really strong and although I did
say the plan production in the late game
is often not worth it because it's just
too expensive for what it gives you for
the last couple of generations naturally
if we're talking about these babies it's
different because these cards are so
good especially considering that these
cards come with VP attached to them and
the reason why plain production is so
good in the big game and Greenery is
generally there's a good in the date
game is because they give you a lot of
VP it gives you one VP for the greenery
one VP for the oxygen and one VP next to
a CD could even give more of this next
to two of your cities so with plan
production out of the way and playing
production is really a mid game thing to
be honest then you can see the theme
about the mid to late game is getting
the cine energies that gives you a lot
of points so floral synergy green text
energy Awards and the Joven amplifiers
and other cards such as straight up
gives you VP this is like the stuff you
want to look at in the second half of
the game this is where I can score a lot
of points so let's talk about floaters
floaters is only if you're playing with
the Venus expansion but at this point
I'm kind of assuming that you are if
you're not then skip this chapter of
course Lotus energy it can generate a
lot of VP I think some people are
underestimating how many points you can
actually get from floaters it's quite
insane and because I feel like most of
the Florida cards are here to actually
give you a lot of VP this is why we're
focusing on this in the mid to late game
except for a few cards there are
actually a few floater cards that are
better suited for the early game so
let's look at them so here the Florida
cards that are pretty good in the early
game and to be honest at this point you
probably know why this is the stuff that
gives you some sort of card draw on the
creative production or engine and then
you might be thinking what about Titan
floating Launchpad and what about
Admiral collectors why are these good in
the early game but these are cards from
the colonies expansion so if you're
playing with these cars you are playing
with colonies the library if established
by now it's really good to be able to
trade so if you're having one of these
two cards in the opening hand then you
probably don't even need to get free
energy production and that could be
really good it can save you a lot of
gold and then of course there are a few
of the other cards here that could be
situationally good in the early game as
well like you it's a floating station if
you have like three science cards and a
bunch of durians but probably you don't
have that in the early game so this is
probably better in the mid game to be
honest and then Saturn surfing is also
good in the early game if you have a lot
of Earth attacks this is one that's
probably more realistic it's more
realistic you have a bunch of Earth
attacks than you have science or jovians
because Earth attacks are more related
to Mega credit production and stuff like
this so it would make sense that you
have some Earth tags in the early game
especially if you got lucky and you got
like a quiet company so some of these
Earth Tech gold production cars
something like this but with that out of
the way I think a lot of these cards are
more suited to generating you a lot of
VP or TR or something you can use in the
mid to late game I think a pretty clear
and a pretty powerful way to get VPS off
of floaters would be to pick up like
Joby and lanterns or floating apps these
two cards are really good and the reason
they grew of course is that if you put
floaters on this card you get like half
a point per floaters and you can put a
lot of floaters during the game the
topless is a little bit worse in this
regard because it only gives you one
third of a point per floater however
sautopolis has a lot of other uses as
well it's really powerful in some combos
we're gonna get to that in a second and
also notably statue police can put two
floaters on the card so if you put it on
itself that alone is like two thirds of
a point every generation and here's a
fun little step that I noticed after I
made this slide look there are nine
Jovian tags on the floaters that's
exactly the same amount as there are
Venus tags so this once again underlines
the point that I'm trying to make that
with all these Jovian tags and stuff
like this these are really cars that are
better suited for the mid to late game a
lot of them I think so here's the most
interesting stat about these cars and
the whole reason I think Jovian lanterns
and floating has such good cards look at
this 16 of these cards has the ability
to put floaters on a different card and
you might be thinking but they're only
15 arrows here but that's because
there's also airliners I just I I gotta
be honest I couldn't fit it on my slice
so here it is but if we're being
perfectly honest who the hell cares
about eyeliner but the point here is
really there's so many cards that can
actually just boost your job in Lansing
so your floating head so it can give you
a lot of points if you have some of
these combinations here then we also got
a couple of corporations that can give
you floaters and we also have tits in a
colony that can give you floaters so I
thought a lot about this and I boiled it
down to the five most important things
you can do with floaters first of all we
talked about this you look for domain
lanterns a floating heads and then you
just Spam floaters on these cards like
an absolute Maniac this could generate
you like a lot of points it's really
powerful and secondly you can look for
floater combo that's actually quite a
lot of these here's some examples for
example we talked about autopolis this
is a really good card in conjunction
with something like fourth precipation
for instance so it's a bit similar to
the micro combo I showed you earlier in
this video the idea is you can get one
free tier or every generation and like
we talked about as long as there are
Venus to be had this is kind of like
eight Mega critic production that's
worth and the reason I write that this
is like sort of worth 10 mega creative
production is because that's open is the
card itself also comes with two maker
foreign
once again this can generate like a lot
of points this is exactly 1.5 VP per
generation because autopolis is going to
give you like one point and then the
card itself is also capable of giving
you like half a point every generation
then you might be thinking well it's
actually cost two Mega credit but two
Mega credit every generation that's
actually the same as a two Mega credit
production you get from sotopia so it
works out and here is one of the sickest
late game combos you can get with
floater so here we've got hydrogen to
Venus and floating Habs so this you
typically also want to play in the last
generation or maybe just before the
Venus closest or something like this
hydrogen to Venus is actually so cheap
that you can also use it in a different
way you can use it earlier to just get
one Venus so you can play something like
venusian animals or something but
generally speaking I really want to save
this card for the last generation
because together with something like
floating Habs it can generate a lot of
points if you think about this card is
like half a German amplifier when you
use it on something like floating apps
because all of the floaters are like
worth half a point per floor so this is
really good especially considering how
cheap it is because this also has a
space and an event Tech she answers are
that with me talking about the last
generation you do has a discount
especially on Space tags there's a lot
of discounts and of course the downside
of this card is what if you don't get
floating heads or jumping lanterns or
statue police then the card is of course
not good so these are some of the really
good combo some of the combos that can
read they win you the game but you don't
really have to get all the really good
combos there's a lot of like small
combos that are just fine that is good
enough an example could be this one
floor technology plus aerial mappers so
when you think about it this is just one
free card every generation it's fine
it's actually exactly the same as sub
cross measurements and the funny thing
is the cost is also almost the same so
it's not fantastic but it's not bad
either it's okay and maybe you get some
discount or maybe you can use the
science tag for something else could
also be something simple like Florida
technology with Titan shuttle so
basically you're pumping floaters on
this card so every Florida is like worth
one titanium so if you think about it
then floating technology is basically
one titanium production once again it's
not amazing but it's something it's not
bad now number three you aim to get the
hoverlot and the vener file this is like
one of the biggest thing you can do with
Venus tags and floaters in general the
thing is if you play it like they
originally intended then every game is
gonna have have a lot and venophile so
hoverlot is a milestone which you can
claim by getting seven floaters and the
venophile is the award for most Venus
techs makes sense that you have a lot of
Venus text if you're going for floaters
you might not necessarily but it would
make a lot of sense if you have and
number four you can also play some of
the really powerful cards with Venus
requirement and I say that it's a few
good cards which is true but the biggest
one by far is venusian animals and as
you can no doubt see from these pictures
here I really like venusian animals this
is like such a good car it can give you
so much points so just having an animal
card with animals being worth one
Victory Point per animal that by itself
is worth something and then like I
mentioned in the previous episode what
you can do is you can have this card in
your hand for a very long time until the
Venus is finally up there or you can
even keep it on your hand even longer
and then in the last generation or at
least in the late game or something you
can just slam down Venus animal and slam
down all the time attacks you've been
holding in your hand just so you can get
that extra 1vp per side effect one VP
per Science Tech makes a lot of science
text insanely good and finally the last
thing I want to make clear about
floaters is that most of these cars are
just good enough by themselves I mean
you don't even have to have a good combo
for these cards to be worth it I don't
think that all of these cards as a whole
is stronger than the colony cast I think
the colonies are stronger but that being
said a lot of these cars are just solid
by themselves so I just wanted to
mention this just in case you're like
all right we're talking about Florida
Synergy it's only good if you get like a
combo or some Synergy a lot of these
cards actually quite good by themselves
they're not bad not bad at all so these
are the top five things to keep in mind
when you're going for floaters I could
be forgetting something here but if I am
I'm sure you'll write it in the comments
thank you and number 13 also in the mid
to late game we are looking at Green
Tech Synergy so once again we talked a
lot about this in the previous video in
episode 3 part 2 but here are some of
the important things to keep in mind
when we're talking about Green text
first of all if you're going for green
text then meat Industries Topsail
contract and also if you're playing with
turmoil you can get GMO contract these
cards are stupidly powerful this is like
going guard mode with Green Tech it's
really good I think green text can of
course generate a lot of points with
microbe so for example if you have amps
or venusian insects then you could get
some nice combo with extreme cold
funkers or this new card back to viral
research and also decomposers can give
you a lot of points as well and when it
comes to animals you really want at
least one card where the animals are
worth one Victory Point per animal and
the reason is there is also a ton of
cards in this game that can give animals
to another card like for example large
Convoy or something and here is like the
best example I can give you of how green
text can actually generate so many
points so we got Advanced ecosystem it's
worth three victory points you play this
in the last generation however if you
also have vile enhanced decomposers and
ecological Zone then all of a sudden
this is like five victory points instead
of three and also you get three pants
this is by the way also just another
reason why you play Advanced ecosystems
in the last generation maybe you pick up
battle enhances a decomposer so
ecological zones or something that makes
this cat better in the late game because
these green VP amplifiers how you can
generate a lot of points with the green
text energy like if I'm going for green
tag I'm having a good game I'm going for
the card strategy I play a lot of green
tags it feels like this is even stronger
than jovians it feels like this is
actually generating more points of job
Intex here is an example of a game where
I got a lot of points from Green text
and keep in mind this is on the master
so this is only vanilla and Prelude I
don't even have a lot of the cards here
and in the mid to late game at this
point we should definitely also think
about the awards so here are the awards
from the original map and worth noting
here that when I say that you should
look at this stuff in the mid to late
game specifically I'm talking about the
second and the third award that cost 14
Mega crits and 20 Mega credits to be
honest the first Fonda that cost 8 Mega
credits that one is probably already got
in the mid game but the one that costs
14 and the one that costs 20. honestly
these are not that important it's okay
if you just wait until the mid to late
game before you go for these so the
first award should be claimed maybe in
the early to mid game but to be honest
only if you're really sure that you're
actually gonna win this award otherwise
don't do it the second award that costs
14 maybe in the mid game is reasonable
and the last one that costs 20 there's
definitely a mid to late game thing
don't start this too early it's really
not worth it and if someone else gets it
fine they just spend 20 Mega credits to
get five victory points it's not that
big of a deal and maybe they won't even
win that award and even if they do win
it then maybe you'll get a second place
that's just been 20 Mega credits to get
three weeks three points over you it's
not that important and finally the last
thing you do in a game of terraforming
Mars is you want to score as many VP as
humanly possible and then change the
text a little bit here because it used
to say another BP cards but then I
realized it's not even limited to cards
you just have to look at all your
available plays really basically which
place gives you the most VP in the late
game and then you just go for that play
So examples of this could be Jovian
amplifiers these are great cards to play
in the last generation except fire
mining industry you usually want to play
that a bit sooner but the other three
Academy Colony what I import from Europa
terraforming Academy those are usually
cars you want to play in the very last
generation could also be just normal
cars that does nothing for you except
give you VP these cards you also want to
save in your hand so you can play them
in the very last generation but that's
pretty much it for this literal recipe
for success or whatever you want to call
it basically all the synergies you want
to look at at the different times of the
game there's a few other minor synergies
we haven't talked about like water
Synergy but to be honest that's only if
you've got Arctic algae Lakefront
Resorts and then I guess also the hidden
water Synergy is if you are building a
lot if you're like going all in on
cities or on greeneries or both then
water Synergy is a little bit better
because you can set yourself up to get
some nice placement bonuses then I guess
I haven't really talked about Science
Tech Synergy enough but I think I'll
save that for episode 7 called what
everything is worth because I kind of
felt that this episode here should be
dedicated to this recipe to be honest
science text can be played in any phase
of the game really you could say the
science tags are closely related to card
throw so it's really good in the early
to mid game or something like this but
to be honest I mean there's so many
different science texts that they do a
bunch of different things so you can't
really say the science take a better in
the early game or the mid game or the
late game it really just depends on
which science attacks we're talking
about I will quickly mention that there
are a bunch of science synergies that
you should really keep your eye out for
so for example we had this example
before but like research got two science
tags so that's basically two cards and
one Victory Point unless you have all of
this stuff then it's a lot better so if
you got Olympus conference March
University the new scene animals then
all of a sudden just the cap research is
worth three cards a rotation of two
cards and three victory points I think I
made this wrong so the only types of
synergy that I can think of that I
didn't really mention much in this
episode is like attacks themselves what
is the sign tag worth what are the Earth
tag worth and so on but just a quick
couple of words Venus text is like
science text in my opinion it could be
played in any phase of the game
depending on which Venus attacks we're
talking about Venus attacks are also
closely related to the Venus scale and
floaters and hoverlon and venophile and
some of the stuff we already talked
about here I've got Jovian tags I've
talked a lot about this in the last
episode called strategies and then the
job in strategy but generally speaking
German tax should be played in the mid
to late game except for the cards that
gives you money income but even then
it's not always the case sometimes even
though you have iron mining Industries
in your hand you kind of want to play it
in the mid game because the cards are so
expensive so maybe you have better place
available to you in the early game and
also a card like callista panel mines
yes it gives you three Mega credit
production but it's so expensive so
exactly a bad way to build your engine
using this card hopefully you have some
better way to build your engine and then
these kind of expensive driving tags
even stuff like panel mines are best
played in the mid game Earth tags
generally speaking should be played in
the early to mid game because if tags
are really closely related to make a
creative production usually so keep in
mind I'm not saying that all Earth tags
should be playing in the early game and
if you play them in the late game it's
bad I'm just really oversimplifying here
like for example media archives is a car
that's really good in the mid to late
game and this has an effect and once
again we'll talk about all the texts and
what they're worth and stuff like this
in episode 7. and that's pretty much it
for this episode so thanks for watching
as always if you have any suggestions
anything I missed any discussion you
want to start with me I'm game just
write it in the comments and I realize a
lot of this stuff in this episode I
talked about in previous episodes but
I'm kind of making these lists of
exactly what I want to think about in
the different phases of the game so I
kinda have to include it anyway I hope
you still had fun and maybe learn
something uh maybe a lot